(cris et applaudissements)
Trois chefs, trois campagnes,
un même arrêt. En 36 heures,
Hamilton s'est retrouvée sous
les projecteurs de l'élection.
L'incarnation des espoirs
de chaque parti.
EMMANUELLE RICHEZ, politologue,
Université de Windsor, Ontario
- Ce que les études révèlent,
c'est que le candidat local a un
impact très limité sur le vote.
Un maximum de 15 % lorsqu'on est
en présence d'un candidat
vedette. Et donc, c'est surtout
la performance du chef
qui importe.
- On voit des courses entre
le Parti libéral et le Parti
conservateur ou entre le NPD
et le Parti libéral. Donc,
tous les partis ont des sièges
à gagner ici et aussi à
sauvegarder. Ce sont des sièges
où il n'y a pas une culture
politique très... très arrêtée,
soit conservateur, soit libéral.
- Une ville, cinq
circonscriptions et trois partis
convaincus qu'ils peuvent
faire des gains ici.
- Nick Milanovic tente sa chance
pour une seconde fois dans
la circonscription ouvrière
de Hamilton-Est-Stoney Creek.
L'avocat né de parents
immigrants a consacré
sa carrière à lutter contre
les injustices et défendre
les plus vulnérables.
Profondément ancré dans
son milieu, il est persuadé
que cette fois, c'est la bonne.
Quelques kilomètres plus loin,
Dan Muys s'est donné
pour mission de conserver
Flamborough-Glanbrook sous
la bannière conservatrice.
Une migration sur laquelle
compte aussi son rival.
Depuis 2013, la marge
des conservateurs ici s'effrite.
Flamborough-Glanbrook est
maintenant dans la mire
des libéraux.
De nouveaux électeurs qui
arrivent majoritairement
de Toronto pour s'établir dans
une ville où ils ont les moyens
de devenir propriétaires.
Paradoxalement, cela vient
exacerber un problème auquel
les partis promettent
de s'attaquer.
- La question du logement
et de la difficulté, voyons,
de se procurer des logements
devient de plus en plus
préoccupante.
♪ ♪ ♪
- Dans ce quartier d'Hamilton,
260 nouvelles unités
d'habitation ont été mises
en vente au printemps dernier.
8500 personnes ont exprimé
leur intérêt. Tout s'est envolé
en une fin de semaine.
- Je pense que c'est
une préoccupation importante.
Mais la manière de la traduire
dans un enjeu électoral, c'est
plus difficile parce qu'il y a
une différence entre quelqu'un
qui cherche à acheter
sa première maison et quelqu'un
d'autre qui a de la misère
à même louer ou trouver
un appartement à louer
avec ses faibles revenus.
- Dans cette région de l'Ontario
à la fois industrielle, urbaine
et rurale, la campagne est
serrée et le résultat,
difficile à prévoir.
- Oui, il faut jamais
sous-estimer le jeu de terrain.
Si un parti décide de mettre
toutes ses ressources dans
un comté chaud, ça peut
définitivement faire
une différence.
- Une chose sera le taux de vote
par anticipation, donc, jusqu'à
quel point est-ce qu'il y a
toujours des électeurs qui n'ont
pas voté, qui sont incertains.
- La lutte dans Hamilton
d'ici au 20 septembre sera
attentivement surveillée.